So that's it for clustering, that's what I wanted to tell you about. Did
you want to help me remember what we learned? What, what did we talk about?
>> So, we talked about clustering, as an idea, which is sort
of a pretty powerful one. And I guess we, we connected that
to the notion of compact description. And we talked about a bunch
of algorithms, and in particular we
talked about k-means and single-linkage clustering.
>> That's right, and there was another one.
>> EM.
>> Yes.
>> And the big difference between
EM and the other two is that EM makes for soft clusters versus hard clusters.
>> Yeah, that's one distinction. You could also say that the difference
between single-link clustering and the others
is it actually terminates in polynomial time.
>> Mm. Doesn't k-means terminate kind of fast?
>> I, I don't think we know, exactly. I think it
could run through a lot of different configurations before it stops.
>> So we talked about some algorithms. And then we did something rather
startling, and we showed that clustering is in some sense impossible.
>> [LAUGH] Right, which is silly because we know that it's possible, we do
it all the time. But we can't
have those particular three properties all at once.
>> Right.
>> That axiomatization is mutually contradictory.
>> Mm-hm
>> Yeah, I think, I think that's about it.
So I'm ready to move onto some other unsupervised topics.
>>
Huh. Cool. Me too. All right, well thanks, Michael. I learned a lot.
>> Sure, yeah. I think next time
you're going to tell me about something, features.
>> I'm a tell you about something. Features.
>> All right! Well, I'm looking forward to something, features.
>> Okay! Bye, Michael.
>> See you.